paul scully is with us should she have
the opportunity to face the british
court i think the supreme court has
ruled on the on on this matter what i
don't want to do i mean it'd be
interesting to see
the extent of the interview but
in terms of the actual case what i don't
want to do is have it out
via broadcast it needs to be heard it
has been heard at the supreme court
after the um home secretary made a
really clear ruling yeah one wonders i
mean she says that she was groomed she
said she's 22 now
um
and she's sorry but she wants to face
justice in a british court
i think it's reasonable to say before
seeing all of the interview that people
should be allowed to repent shouldn't
they yeah i think what is the reason
that i say that um the decisions
shouldn't be taken although the the
interest of the interview is interesting
uh the decisions shouldn't be taken out
in public because the home secretary
took his decision with intelligence
documents with other documents that i
haven't seen uh that we haven't seen so
in order to take that complete um uh
decision it's really important that they
have both sides of the story which
they've had as i say in making the
decision and at the supreme court which
validated the decision of the home
secretary at the time it would be humane
to i mean she's she's stateless at the
moment
don't we have a responsibility to um at
least give her the opportunity to have
her case heard in the uk well i think as
i say the case itself has been heard i
think she's uh she's obviously has a her
is getting her voice across through
through your program here and through
other channels as well i've seen a a
number of um reports in in
print journalism as well uh so so that
is coming across but nonetheless this
these are really pivotal decisions
rightly so because it's about national
security it's about um uh actors the in
the traveling to other countries to do
damage against um british interests
do we think she's still a threat to
national security that i can't tell i
mean i i you know i've seen the
interview there but as i say i'm not
privy to intelligence documents so it's
not i'm sure you know uh quite a lot
about what's happening with uh social
care there's a vote in the house of
commons later on today the pm promise
that no one would have to sell their
homes to pay for their care is that
still the case
what we've said is that we've been
consistent right the way through this is
that uh you won't have to
spend um any more money that the cap is
there with over 86 000 pounds
and that is indeed the case so it's um
the um
uh andrew dillon himself said that in
fact it was five times more generous
than the existing scheme uh at the
moment and so yes that is indeed the
case yeah
so you won't have to sell your house
well not until you you know you you've
reached the capitol the prime minister
said you won't have to sell yourself and
effectively you won't have to pay any
more money above above above the cap
that's that's essentially it as a for
your uh for for the um the personal care
that you get but it did make a big play
about not having to sell your house so
is that going to be the case or not well
you know depending on different
circumstances what i'm saying what i'm
saying is that there was there was
you people want to know the detail of
the policy clearly they want to know
exactly what's going to happen and
that's what we've
um the care minister announced last
thursday that's what we're voting on
today is that if you um
if you hit the cap you will not have to
pay any more money for your personal
care i think that's there's a fair
balanced approach um for
taxpayers and for people that are um
that are having to pay for what is
effect are really expensive at the
moment um for form of care through
social care
yeah but the headline was that the pm
promised as part of the last election
that no one would have to sell their
homes to pay for their care i think
details of what's important because
people lots of people got you know
something the detail is you either have
to sell your house some people don't
have homes some people you know have
homes of different amounts what do you
say what is really what
what we're trying to do is find a
cross-party consensus approach that
actually tackles an issue that has been
around for
a
decade you know at least a decade in
terms of this thorny issue because we've
not been able to find a satisfactory
solution so it's always been kicked onto
the longest what we're now in the
position to do is to uh to say there is
the cap there is the the uh above which
you will not have to pay for social care
which is a fair and balanced approach he
was telling lies then in order to win
the election no no i don't think it was
what what he did he promised he was born
he was boiling down a complicated
message um which is why as i say social
care hasn't been dealt with in in at
least 10 years to to something that
people could appreciate people could see
where we were coming from now the detail
is there and that that's that's that's
the approach um okay so if your house is
worth under 80 000 pounds um any
government contributions won't count
towards the cap so if you are in care
for a long time how can you avoid
selling your house
well
the government contributions are um are
one thing that essentially it's what you
are having to pay out of your own pocket
in terms of uh
to towards that cap and i think that's
right that it that's concentrating on
what you personally are having to pay
um
for personal care or
effectively you get to that cat not
having to pay but if your house is worth
under 80k if you take all of that into
account then you're going to have to how
can you avoid selling your house if
you're in long-term care well i'll come
back to the point that what we're
talking about is what you are having to
pay there is a cap that at the moment it
was 20 000 pounds it's now it's now a
lot higher than that and so we're being
more generous um than the current system
it's a it's a fairer ballot balanced
system for people
that are able to get to that point when
they get to the cap and not having to
pay any more which that you know you you
107 constituencies in the north where
homes are worth less will be impacted
that's according to um research 107
separate constituencies none in the
south at all how's that leveling up
it's
what it's approaching it's approaching a
cap it's it's it's you've got to look at
the cap you've got to look at the fact
that if people are approaching the cap
when they get over that they are not
having to pay any more money i mean it's
difficult for me to sit here and talk
about
individuals
but clearly
it's natural that
it's it's a it's a clear fact of um
uh statement of fact that houses in the
south are far more expensive
you're more likely to be able to keep
your house but it's all about it's all
about what you pay and how much you can
but how's that leveling up
because it's about what you pay it's not
just solely about a single house it's
about do you remember so why did the
prime minister not know that when he
makes a cap above which and when you do
you do not have to pay so why don't you
make the promise because this is
something we're trying to tackle look
we're trying to tackle what promises you
don't keep time and time and time again
and next people expect people to vote
for because if we boil it all down to
one line then you get to a situation
that you'll never
there is a reason that social care has
not been sorted for ten years it's
because it's complicated it's thorny it
deserves more than just a single just
saying it that's deal not who you quoted
says the savings will be exclusively
from those with fewer assets and he's
also explained that how's that leveling
up well he's also explained that it's
far more generous than the current
system um and so as i say the whole
reason that social care has not been
tackled until now is because it deserves
more than a single line of single
headlines you acknowledged that it was
misleading what the prime minister was
saying no what i'm saying is that the
fact that we've got a cap and that's
it's the cap that we've always been
trying to tackle the cap
there will be fewer people um selling
their houses um and
and hopefully none but but the point is
some people from what you're saying some
people may have to sell that but there
will be fewer people saying that i can't
tell you what you know what people
individuals are going to do what i'm
saying is the prime minister what i'm
saying is the social care solution is
all about getting a cap above which you
do not need to pay that gift that gives
people certainty respect mr scully why
then didn't the prime minister say fewer
people will have to sell their houses
that's not what he said ahead of the
election he said people will not have to
sell their homes to pay for their long
term come back to the point if we boil
it all down to to a single headline then
you'll never issue anything you never
tackle any thorny issue like social care
there were so many there were lots of
things policies that we can tackle
through um a single bill of legislation
social care is nothing but knowledge
that some people will have to sell their
homes we need a cross-party consensus
okay let's move on to migrants should
you 24 700 people have so far across the
channel this year um
pretty patel pontificates like some
bystander it's her responsibility
pretty patel if i wanted uh someone to
be firm on immigration it'd be pretty
patella i'd have the same secretary so
it again it's a complicated situation
why because you've got um there are only
certain ways of actually tackling
immigration across the channel illegal
immigration across the channel we're
legislating for it so actually if people
will be treated differently if they've
come across
as an illegal immigrant at the moment
that's not the only five were sent back
last year but twenty four thousand seven
hundred people
but that's why we're changing that's
exactly why we're changing the law
that's exactly why we're changing the
law because at the moment you cannot
differentiate between people that are
legal migrants or legal migrants the the
nationalities bill will change that
however the only other ways of doing it
are we get the french to uh to fulfill
their the obligations that they promised
us to be able to have a hundred percent
of to remove 100 of people
traveling in the first place or we um
all we um police an incredibly uh wide
open bit of um sea
uh which is incredibly difficult
for military patrol do you think that's
a good idea but it's one of the busiest
shipping lanes in the world and it's in
how do we do it it's far better to do it
at source to do it on the french border
is military patrol
the best way of doing it is on french
land and of course we could do before
brexit
but we because of the 2k agreement well
we can do it through the agreement that
we have with the french at the moment
which isn't happening and that's why
pretty patel is having conversations
with the french authorities we've paid i
think it's 54 million pounds to to not
pay them yet they'll have to help them
in that we haven't paid them yet have we
we've offered to help to help them
police them because we still owe them
the money we've offered we've helped
offer them to police that uh that board
have we pay the money well that i don't
know because i'm not a home minister
home office minister but your part but
nonetheless well let's see if they can
actually do the job that we promised
before we started okay her colleagues
british patel's colleagues said in the
papers at the weekend that she's a
why is she not
um she said she was a who said
that her um civil servants who work with
her okay well that's a speculation that
i'm not really not going to get involved
my question is why is she not i i just
don't think name calling is particularly
handy pretty is a an effective home
minister home office minister that's
tackling
any number she's more than that she's
the home secretary and her civil servant
they think she's a i mean goodness
me actually coming out to say that there
must be some disquiet in the ranks there
no you've you've cited maybe one person
speculatively i've got no idea um
how aggrieved they are what what the
motivation behind that pretty patel is
doing a
incredibly difficult job that's home um
at the moment well look you've talked
about lots of different 24 700 people
have come over so far this year yeah
because we because we've made an
agreement with france which
unfortunately is not being affected um
well enough at the moment and that's
what we need to go back and do that's
why we're changing she's not being
effective that's why we changed it all
you can't change the law overnight we've
been in two years we've been talking
about secretary and we can't change the
law overnight the law the the we're
going through the parliamentary process
of the nationalities bill which will
make it um be able to treat illegal
immigrants differently to legal
illegal migrations my migration has been
a thorny issue for probably about 20
years now and we're actually going to be
in the hundreds before brexit now it's
uh 24 07. one of the things we've got to
do is we've got to stop the pull factors
we've got to stop the um the reason why
people are traveling through safe
countries through france to come to the
uk and one of the ways that we're doing
that is to legislate why do you think
they don't
why do you think they do
there's any number of reasons why
because at the moment we've got to make
sure that actually they're treated well
in france in the first place that they
they are claiming asylum that's what the
rules are that's what the laws are and
then when they're coming there's a
number of um asylum seekers that carry
on going to to germany to sweden to
other countries uh except that they're
desperate people but there are human
traffickers that are actually saying you
know what you can cross the border
because it's too
in the lives of their children we have
to accept that they are desperate people
they are desperate people who are being
fed by some of the lowest people in the
world the human human traffickers and
whilst they can see actually there's a
pathway through across the channel
because the border hasn't been enforced
well enough on the land side on the
french side and whilst we're not allowed
to
treat illegal immigrants differently
from legal immigrants then those pull
factors remain that's what we're
tackling and that's what we are trying
to tackle at full speed it's always good
to talk to you sadly we're out of time
thanks very much indeed for joining us
this morning thank you